you and uh joe have had a bunch of
conversations
and they're
always incredible thanks so in terms of
this dance of conversation of your
friendship
of when you get together like what is
that world you go to that creates
magic together because we're talking
about how we do that with robots
how do these two biological robots do
that can you introspect that i met joe
because i was a i was the talent
coordinator of the comedy store this
club in l.a
and my job was to take phone calls from
comics and so at some point i don't know
joe i ended up on the phone with joe and
we just started talking
and
you know i looked up and like 30 minutes
had passed we just been talking for like
30 minutes that's what our friends are
you know we're just like we're having
fun talking and then he would just call
and we would talk and we would basically
i mean it was no different from the
podcast like we
though the conversations we we have on
the podcast are identical to the
conversations we had before he was even
doing a podcast so i think uh
people are just seeing two friends
hanging out
who like talking to each other yeah but
there's a there's this
weird like you you serve as catalyst for
each other to go into some crazy places
so it's like uh it's a balance of
curiosity and willingness
to not be constrained
uh to not be limited to the constraints
of reality
yeah yeah in your exploration place it's
a very very nice way of saying that
and you just like build on top of each
other like uh
you know what if things are like this
and you feel like lego blocks on top of
each other and it just goes to crazy
places add some drugs into that and just
goes wild yeah and you know he like it's
so cool because it's like uh
you know it's a it's a it's a for me
it's like a really it's like sometimes
maybe i'll throw something out
that he will take and the lego building
blocks you're talking about they lead to
him saying like the funniest [ __ ] i ever
in my life so it's that's a cool thing
to watch it's just like some idea you've
been kicking around you watch his brain
shift that into like something supremely
funny yeah i really love that man that's
just like a fun thing to like
see happen he knows that i [ __ ] hate
the videos
of animals eating each other like i
don't like that i don't want to watch it
i hate watching it
i don't think i've even articulated on
his podcast how much
i dislike it when he shows animals
eating each other but he knows because
he knows me
and so he tortures you like when he
starts doing that it's like this kind of
benevolent torture is he like asking
jamie to pull up
increasingly disturbing animal attack
videos so it's just a it's a it's just
even in torture because i'm reading
about torture in the gulag archipelago
currently there's a bit of a camaraderie
you're in it together
the torture and the tortured what
oh god that's so [ __ ] up man i've
never
no i i mean part of it was joke but as i
was saying it that you're right that
also comes out in the in the book
because they're both [ __ ] they're both
they're both um have no control of their
fate
um that's the same was true in
the camp guards and nazi germany and and
the people in the camps
the worst was brought out in the guards
uh but they were all in it together in
some dark way
they're both [ __ ] by a very powerful
system that put them in that place yeah
and both of us could be either player in
that system which is the dark reality
that soldier knits and also
reveals
that uh the line between good and evil
runs to the heart every man as he wrote
in gulag archipelago
but it is that amidst all that there's a
i don't know the good vibes the
positivity comes out from the both of
you and that's beautiful to see that is
i suppose friendship uh what do you
think makes a good friend
oh god i mean it's a bill you know it's
a billion it's a billion things that
make a good friend but i think you could
break it down to some rgb i think you
can go rgb with like a good friendship
oh in terms of the color the red green
yeah yeah i think you could probably
come up with some like fundamental
qualities of friendship and i'd say
uh
number one it's love like it's
friendship is love it's uh it's a form
of love uh
so
obviously without that i don't know how
you
i mean i'm not saying i think if you're
true friends you love each other so you
need that but love obviously it's not
it's
that's not it that's not enough it's
like
with
uh
true friends have to be like incredibly
honest with each other and not like you
know what i mean but not like uh
i don't like i think there's a kind of
like i don't know if you've ever noticed
like some people who say you know i just
tell it like it is yeah but the thing
they do those are always the [ __ ]
yeah why is it that your talent like it
is is always negative why is it it's
always cynical or shitty or you're like
nagging somebody or me how come you're
not telling it like it is when it's good
too yeah you know what i mean so we sort
of like trust but
but
a pro evolutionary kind of trust you
know what i mean like you know that
your friend loves you and
wants you to be yourself because if you
weren't yourself then you wouldn't be
their friend you'd be some other thing
but also
they might be seeing your blind spots
that other people in your life your
family
your wife whoever might not be seeing
yeah so that's a good friend as someone
who like loves you enough to when it
matters
be like hey
are you all right
and then help you see something you
might not be seeing
but hopefully they only do that once or
twice a year you know yeah
there's something i i mean you just
would have
this world especially in if you're a
public figure this this world
has its
uh
has its
plenty of critics
and it feels like a friend
uh the criticism part
is already done
for you
i think a good friend is just there to
support to actually notice the good
stuff but in comedy
we need like that what what like it's
really good in comedy to have someone
you can like be like what do you think
of that
and know that they're not going to be
like that that's for the craft the craft
itself like the work you do not the
uh
yeah
interesting but that's so tough
yeah whatever your particular art form
or whatever you are doing i mean you
don't always be leaning on your friends
opinions for like your own innovation
but it's nice to know that you have
someone who not just with jokes but with
anything if you go to them and run
something by them they're going to like
they're going to be honest with you
about like their their real feelings
regarding that thing because that helps
you grow as a person we need that and it
hurts sometimes and we don't want to
hurt our friends one of the more satanic
like impulses when you're with somebody
is is not wanting to
honestly answer
whatever they're asking in that regard
or wanting to like put their temporary
feelings over something that you've
recognized is maybe not great i'm i'm
not saying a friendship is
something where you're always critiquing
or evolving each other it's not your
therapist or whatever but it's nice when
it's there you know i think that's
another aspect of
friendship yeah but yeah love is at the
core of that you've noticed i've met
people in my life where almost
immediately sometimes it takes time
where you notice like there's a magic
between the two of you like oh [ __ ] you
seem to be made from the same cloth
yeah whatever that is well you know we
have a name for that in the spiritual
community it's called satsang and it's i
love the idea
it's uh
basically like if nietzsche's idea of
infinite recurrence is true
then your sat song would be the people
you've been infinitely recurring
with and those are the people where you
run into them
and you've never met them but it's like
you're picking up a conversation
that
i've never had yeah that uh and that
that you know that is based on an idea
of like this isn't the only life it's we
we're always hanging out together we
always show up together
you